Matthew Lesko your author of information
USA and you say that what the government
creates most is information how easy is
it for our viewers to get up some of
that information well depends I mean
it's not easy stuff to do you know if
you go out the window here you know and
look out around town you don't see any
smokestacks
now we got our like a trillion dollar
budget nowadays but it is all
information you know but the biggest
problem is nobody advertises that this
stuff is there but you want to know what
career to get into well down the street
here we have a hundred people that just
spend their career studying what career
you should you know get into you don't
have to spend money on a career
counselor you know money to get started
business I found 50 different programs
to help people finance businesses even
in this administration
you know money for college I found 67
programs for people you know to finance
college education you want to start a
pizza you know shop or something like
that you can find a pizza expert dollar
Department of Commerce who spends a
career studying the market for pizza
when I've been doing for the living for
the last like 10 11 years now it's
getting this information I get for free
and I sell it to my clients for as much
as I could get no they're like like
about two weeks ago I had a client of
call that want to start a chain of pasta
stores so I found a pasta expert in the
federal government this guy was
wonderful he spent the last 15 years of
his life studying the pasta market you
know that's all he does you know and
when I found that person the problem
wasn't getting the information the
problem is getting that sucker off the
phone you know I had a feeling he's been
studying pasta for 15 years of his life
and no one's ever asked him about it you
know and and so that's right to me it's
hard in a way because nobody knows it's
there nobody knows where to go and the
average person you know sitting out in
Iowa or wherever if you don't know about
Washington like us who live in the you
know inside the beltway here you know
you make one or two phone calls and you
and you don't get your you know the
right person you don't get help or
whatever and you hang up but there's
help there for anything you know I found
a free report open the National Bureau
of Standards that will help you beat a
traffic ticket a radar it shows you they
spent like thirty thousand dollars a
couple of years ago showing that police
traffic radar is not accurate you know
and I helped the young fellow up in
where was the Hazleton Pennsylvania get
this and he took it a traffic court and
beat a $90 traffic ticket now and this
is free information you know that we all
pay for but very few people use but you
a lot of this information you put it in
this book information USA today and it's
sub headlined the essential guide for
direct access to US government experts
now who is this guide essential well I
actually don't even think you need the
book I mean my theory is this stuff is
there nobody uses it there's even people
in the government that will help you
find it you know I mean your local
congressman's office you could call them
up you know and ask a question I mean
you want to know like the latest cures
the back pain you know well the
congressman's office could give you the
health information Clearinghouse they
have an 800 number you can call them and
they'll switch you like to somebody over
at NIH who spends a career and hundreds
of millions of dollars every year just
stunning back pain now I did it myself
like the foot when I first started this
business you know I had no business I'm
sitting in my bedroom doing nothing you
know and I had back pain for about ten
years of my life and I was I thought was
the funny things they made me sleep when
I was in the Navy and I'd go to my
doctor and he'd say oh let's go your
back pain isn't real bad you know and
everybody's got back pain and so I
called up this 800 number national
health information coming up they
switched me to someone at NIH it was
wonderful I got this fella who's been
studying you know back pain for the last
10 15 years of his life and he also
spends you know government you know
money of hundreds of millions of dollars
to all the researchers all the world of
study this and he was telling me the
results of research that weren't even
published yet like before it shows up in
the New England Journal of Medicine or
anywhere and he was telling was Saudi he
said like the the and this was about oh
about seven eight years ago he said that
the the cure rate for back pain at the Y
program YMCA is around the country of a
back ache program it's like they have a
7080 percent cure rate and I took it up
and the first up here two weeks my back
pain went away you know it's like going
to Oral Roberts aside like this but this
is the federal government you know and
free information but nobody thinks of it
that way and that's right you know most
people hate the government you know
maybe not the people who watch this
channel but you know most around the
country and and I think it's because
they don't use it they don't see the
value of all this information I mean
even now we're in the computerize age
well the government has free databases
you can call up I mean you want to go
get the latest economic statistics we
don't have to dial up some commercial
database vendor who's going to charge a
hundred dollars an hour whatever the
Commerce Department is a free bulletin
board you can call it with your computer
and get the same same information you
know you want to monitor legislation or
something ahead your stuff
in Iowa and you think you have to hire a
high-priced you know a lobbyist in
Washington you know that high-priced
lobbyists is making a few phone calls
like the bill fattest office here and
and somebody for free will will search
that database for you and send you the
printout and you could have that you
know access to that way you in the
middle of the country or or downtown
Washington here but again they don't
advertise so very few people know it's
there our topic for the next hours
government information and how you have
access to it our guests for the next
hour is author Matthew Lesko he's
compiled a book called information USA
which is about how to access government
information sources and we'd like to
hear from you if you have questions or
comments on this you're calling from the
eastern or central time zone the phone
number is two oh two six to eight two
five two five four in the western time
zone or Mountain Time Zone the numbers
202 seven eight three to seven to seven
and tonight we'd especially like to hear
about your experiences of trying to get
government information if you were
successful or not we'd like to hear
about that and also if you're looking
for some now perhaps our our guest has
some ideas about where to look for and I
suspect he will is there any way to
estimate when I got to different numbers
yeah he was trying to explain to me out
of there the lobby or the greenroom
whatever you call it and I wasn't really
sure to me boomers know it gives more
people a chance to fight and they have a
photo it so anyone's like in California
can call both numbers you want to pay
the nickel what the suppose I encourage
people rather because it is separated by
East and West is there any way to
estimate how much money the government
spends gathering information gathering
if I may well I have to make there
there's we got about 300 million federal
employees and I asked them about seven
hundred thousand of those are experts in
something now if they're studying back
pain or main potatoes or pasta or you
know some health care problem I mean
they they spent a career doing that how
much money in the budget well I mean
it's it's amazing that the money in the
budget you know for paper again I mean
you look out here you don't see any
smoke snack so we're not making a whole
lot of stuff besides information you
know and even on Capitol Hill you know
what surprises me is that people on
Capitol Hill you know like people watch
your your program or interested in
legislation I know I don't really care
about legislation but I think Kent
there's so much other stuff like the
three had PhDs appear in the
Congressional Research Service that
grind out term papers every evening on
four hundred current event topics people
think that deal for legislation now and
that's wonderful you know their tongue
papers or current events or or like I'll
get it for a market study on aquaculture
you know we have a PhD up on Capitol
Hill studying the market for aquaculture
and I'll get that for free giving my
clients or hundreds or tens of thousands
of dollars but nobody knows about I'm
going to take our first call for the
night our first call for Matthew Lesko
comes tonight from Schneider Texas
you're on the air
yeah I'd like to ask mr. Lesko the
expense involved in all this information
the government collecting oh I know if
it's after your budget you know or all
your budget I don't even know I mean to
me most of Washington is information on
expertise of some kind besides the the
bombs that we buy or something like that
otherwise we buy very little hardware
anywhere else my problem is is that you
know I don't really care you know and
really you you can cut half of this
government away and throw it away
they'll still be so much that people
don't use you want to know where like
you you've got a hot tip from your
investor on robotics or something you
know your your broker calls you up you
know why trust that sucker we got a five
robotics experts on the federal payroll
that tell you what's going to happen in
that industry in the next 5-10 years and
they're not biased like you're a broker
you ask about our West Coast line we go
out watch out to to Burbank California
you're on the air our surprise people
what you have us worried yeah the day
after Christmas everybody's going to be
you know fat and doing something else
I'm not not go back perfect go ahead
hello versa let's go yes sir
I'd like to first of all applaud you and
your efforts and in bringing this
information to the public
oh I feel like I'm the only person in
the world getting some money back from
the taxes it's amazing your level of
energy and how you maintain it my
question is this is there a database
that that you can dial up with your
modem with your computer that has a list
of other databases that the federal
government provides of information ah
first line I just completed a book that
has identifies four or five thousand
databases now of those that you can
actually dial up through your modem
there's probably only about it maybe
about two dozen or three dozen or
something like that
most of the databases you could you know
call up you know and they'll run a
computer printout for you and send it
now to get a listing of them in once in
one place what I would do is it take me
too long to find the number of my book
right now but just call your local
Department of Commerce you know and
because they have a bulletin board for
statistical economic statistical
information and that all hat also has a
listing of most of the major databases
in the government that are available for
free okay
the he is off the line updated list as
the evening progresses we'll take it in
steps to take us through the process so
let's start first with how does someone
once that once they have a piece of
information they want to find out how do
they expire well they could buy a nice
book that I have if you don't need them
you know if you think of you know
there's some people like wherever you
are in the country or in Burbank you
know California if you look in the white
pages of your phone book under US
government you'll see an office called a
general service administration that has
a special section called a federal
information center and these people like
what I charge my clients seventy-five
bucks an hour to do they'll do for free
you know and they'll find you the main
problem is you can't take no for an
answer you know and that's one thing so
when you get no you have to go somewhere
else then go to your congressman's
office ask them they have a staff
locally you know that even has tile
lines to Washington DC and save you some
phone calls to help you track down this
stuff the main problem is when you get a
no answer you know you just can't take
it no because nobody in the government
knows everything and you just have to
hang in there it's always going to be in
your eyes my theory is it takes an
average of seven phone calls to find an
expert on anything whether it's had a
bit of a solar heated outhouse or or how
to get you know a scholarship to study
food science which they have such a
program over the Department of
Agriculture you know it just takes you
got to hang in there and not get
frustrated keyboard New Jersey you're on
okay thank you very much and good
evening to both of you gentlemen mr.
Lesko it's really great to see somebody
like yourself on TV
and why a light side and but an
accessible sign Washington I like that
I'll call to discuss the NT is national
technical information service huh in the
past I've attempted to get information
and was deterring the expense okay well
my theory you know I've been telling
with your college experience EIS
national technical information service
this is supposedly the depository of
anything that technical is finance or
research in the government is supposed
to be in the national technical
informations are illegal and they have
about 80,000 publications a year but you
know and that's how they're supposed to
make it accessible to you know the
general public however what I found
caller is that in the government the
people are in the business of getting
out information are the last place to go
I don't know if you call the national
technical information or like the first
time I called them I was looking for a
study on so how to build a solar heated
swimming pool it was one of the most
popular studies I called them up and I
asked them for this study had the name
the title and the author they said do
you have the number yeah I said the
viewing number what I forget to what
they called it and I didn't have this
number you know and they said well you
have to have this number so I said well
I have the name you know the author and
the title the service said no you need
this luton number I said where do you
get this number and they said well you
have to write to so-and-so to get this
movie number and I said damn it I don't
want to you know a penpal want to know
how to get this study you know they just
make it so difficult for you but you
know in to my theory in seven phone
calls you can find the sucker of the
government who spent the last seven
years of his life you know doing that
study he's got a garage full of them
with his name on them and love to send
you one for free you know and because
also MT is will get things there six to
eight months late they only get about
20% of what they should have you know I
mean someone like ITA international
terror for administration
they'll have 500 market studies they'll
put out every year that won't even come
near you know NT is so what's the thing
of the subject your interest should go
to the agency you think would handle
them trying to find the person who did
that report because you also know about
the report that's coming out you know in
two days or in six weeks that will
better than the one in NTIS so I use MT
is as a place to last resort when I
can't get anywhere else
caller you mentioned that you'd been
deterred by the cost how much was it
going to cost you to get what you wanted
well I suppose I found it on average if
you were looking for a report done you
know specific possible market research
or an area or whatever rate type of
thing we'll be running a approximately a
grant and that gets difficult for
independents such as you bet else you
know and you know because a lot of times
you may find G like he's saying right
there you you have to call ten different
people lucky you'll bump into someone
that you need and in that case you might
get ten thousand in full addresses and
find one now for $1,000 I can get
expensive I'd rather go to a Thomas's
journal or register Thomas's industrial
register or the gold book or something
else and that's really what it would
I've been forced to but I just wanted to
say I did III think that I allowed
myself to be browbeaten I love I love
mr. Lesko s-- attitude yeah I think it's
great now I'll call and let some other
people have some home okay thank you
very much I was going to give him
another number if he gave me a subject
but so you know callers don't know it
has to give me a specific subject want
information on if I could find it
quickly I could be a phone number who
has it
anybody knows you all are next call this
evening comes from San Diego San Diego
oh good evening how are you good evening
um I have a question in a comment mr.
Lesko mentioned that he should talk to
your Congressman your senator I did
exactly that looking for some combat art
from the Defense Department's and what
combat art art okay I talked with the
senator Cranston's office out here
stopped down there and next thing you
know I've got four or five different
addresses to write to in all kinds of
telephone numbers I wrote to Caspar
Weinberger the Secretary of Defense and
I I'm so far received about six letters
they've sent it on two different pieces
I one thing to remember if you can
afford it I would stay away from sending
paper into Washington
you know I'd use of telephone you know
before I'd send another piece of paper
into this bureaucratic nonsense we have
here
a telephone you know call will get
answered a lot quicker than a piece of
you know paper will in this town so if
you can afford a nickel another thing to
remember the bureaucrats in this town
work early you know so like 7:30 8
o'clock most of the the bureaucrats are
on the payroll so if you're out in San
Diego that's 4 o'clock in the morning
you can call the rates will be pretty
cheap at that time and make a caller to
the place I would go for something like
that 2 is the National Archives they
have so many you know historians you
know that military historians at the
National Archives I get a hold of a
military historian and call the Pentagon
you locally you will have a Pentagon you
know look under US Department of Defense
in your local and ask for the Department
of Army you know a historian and just
call that sucker because he's going to
know more than anybody another question
San Diego ah did you have another
question well I guess my question was
huh uh if I want to publish this if I
want the right to publish this in the
magazine or oh hey okay I know you're an
it question you don't have to get
anybody's if I make a living out of
taking stuff all my books are copies of
government books now actually the first
book I made a New York Times bestseller
I call it getting yours it's a book
that's been published by the Government
Printing Office for the last like
20-some years it was called the catalog
of federal domestic assistance
David Stockman's office where he used to
be that published that for like 20-some
years I took a cut-and-paste of it I
flunked English in college so I'm not
really a writer you know I cut and
pasted this sucker made a New York Times
bestseller and and you know that's legal
in the government you know everything is
owned by us
thank you very much San Diego our topic
tonight is government information and
how you can get it our guest is author
Matthew Lesko he's compiled a book
called information USA the next call
comes from Memphis you're on the air I'm
George W foster jr. and I'm common
efficacy and I want to find out more
about go well she'll be a next book
published all of the information USA
though will come out though since all
this past election came along and
November ah Thank You Memphis the the
current edition just came out about May
last year or this past year my theory is
it doesn't matter election
maksim Yahoo's are kept but I know who
gets voted they don't run this town
really
it's a bureaucrats who are there you
know 30 40 years you know if you want to
get a you know you want to make an
investment in Maine potatoes on a New
York commodities exchange you're not
going to call even if you know the
person who is you know appointed the
sixth Assistant Secretary of Agriculture
well the Assistant Secretary of
Agriculture his average life span there
is like 18 months it takes them two
years to find out where the bathrooms
are on this agency letter loans in the
world a real information is what you're
going to find though you know in a few
phone calls you'll find Charlie Porter
over the Department of Agriculture who
spent the last 18 years of his life
studying Maine potatoes you know and
he's been here 213 administration and
his desk hasn't changed 19 years you
know and that's where the real knowledge
and expertise and institutional
knowledge of our country
is tied up in these mid-level
bureaucrats the other people come and go
too quickly Boulder Colorado your next
call you're on the air hi Matt I want to
ask you a question my mother is about 60
years old she speaks a little French she
wants to go to France run some kind of
government program so that she could go
into the schools and talk about how a
Housewives exist in the United States or
tell them about some of her you know
raising children dates or a legal
background or you know something that
she's done in the past and if there's
some type of government program that
will fly her over put her off give a
Reuben board and either give it a little
snipping so she can stay there for two
three weeks or whatever and accounting
is a government-sponsored the cultural
program there's something like that
exist if it does where do I apply what's
the phone number risk application and
how can I start she wants to go next
week thanks Boulder next week too late I
mean you can't know first of all you
deal with the government no to work for
something you need next week is your
likelihood is pretty slim but let me
give you the phone number the main
program that does exactly that call the
mayor
participants program at USI a like my
wife my wife took advantage of this a
few years ago she used to be a write for
a newsletter that covered Capitol Hill
here and that she quit her job was
hanging around was going to Europe she
called this program at USIA
now they didn't pay her way this time
but what they did they gave her about
three hundred dollars to speak to some
high school students in France they give
her another couple of hundred dollars
speaks in high school students in
Brussels and she didn't speak the
language you know she spoke to English I
said did you get any questions she said
no questions but when she came back what
was neat she got such great reviews they
asked if she wanted to go two weeks all
expenses paid to India because they were
looking for someone to represent America
there so they're looking for a lot you
know just normal folk you know to
represent America you know all over the
world it's called the American
participants program here's the number
it's two oh two four eight five two
seven six four that's two oh two four
eight five two seven six four the other
thing I would do is call the Department
of Education they have an International
Education Clearing House and they get
questions like this all the time and the
research staff up there will be happy to
you know to identify a half a dozen
other more programs that's at the
Department of Education International
Education Clearinghouse our next call we
go to bully Maryland hello a local call
you're on the air yes Miami you now yes
go ahead
what I want to know is I'm interested in
aquaculture uh-huh aqua we're Agri I'm
in Florida here and I hear mr. hunter be
in Alabama has aquaculture never trying
to get information on that angle long
time can you tell me through your book
there sure you don't need the book I'm
sorry not clear you said agriculture
aquaculture what aquaculture that's fish
farms right okay fish farm there's a
couple of places in the government that
we have an aquaculture expert not only
Department of Agriculture but also on
Capitol Hill we have a PhD you know
studying aquaculture over at the
Congressional Research Service but let
me give you the best place to start
here's the US Department of Agriculture
office of information ask for the
aquaculture expert okay and he's at 202
four four seven 800 five two oh two four
four seven eight
Oh five I'm going to give you one other
place to the National Agricultural
library these people will do research
for you for free on any agriculture
aquaculture we loaded related subjects
there are three oh one three four four
three seven five five three oh one three
four four three seven five five okay
you should have any problem at all okay
thank you our last call was from Florida
we now go now we go to blue ears booyah
hello mr. Lesko yes sir ah I had an
interesting question you mentioned
earlier that you had back trouble and
you right okay I have multiple sclerosis
uh-huh into conservatively twenty
knowledge estándar mayshen about what
kind of research is going on and who's
doing what is there any and the MS
Society won't help you with that yeah
and our society gives me absolutely no
and for me that's remarkable okay let me
give you some phone numbers to start
okay and you're right here in Washington
that's right now Ms I don't know exactly
I mean I hear it and I think I know a
lot about it but I don't know what kind
of what other category is that in it's a
neuromuscular disease okay there's one
backup phone number they always keep in
hand for any help the national health
information Clearinghouse which is eight
hundred three three six four seven nine
seven that's 800 336 four seven nine
seven now ask them who you know we're at
NIH or whatever that they they're
studying MS because they have to be if
not what I would do is call the main
office at the Department of Health and
Human Services and ask them for the
office that's studying that if the
health information Clearinghouse doesn't
help you if that doesn't work out you
know give me a call here I'm listed a
I'm in Chevy Chase Maryland and you know
works down a few more things because
health information there's more in the
government of anywhere else and the
reason I don't know if you mentioned
earlier maybe was before like I did a
baby book with my wife it's called a
maternity source book
and the reason I did that look I'm 43
years old I just started having a family
yeah and I thought I'd never have kids
and my wife who was very athletic when
we got pregnant we said we went to the
doctor said how long could we play
tennis you know and the doctor said well
you should quit after six months yeah so
we went to another doctor and asked them
and they said well you should quit after
four months so I said well let's check
somebody else oh we check somebody else
they said after eight months and so it
was getting a clue that no one really
knew so we went up to nih and found out
the latest research that was available
on exercising pregnancy we found that
the only scientific evidence that has
ever done was a study conducted on
pregnant sheep about upstate Washington
somewhere and that was the only thing
other than that everybody was guessing
but they wouldn't tell you that we're
guessing so that's what we did a you
know a health book with all the
information right here in Washington
thanks for your call the way we go back
to the west coast to Bowman California
Beaumont you're on the air
hi mr. Lacombe yes sir I'd like to find
out if possible if there is a government
agency that where we could get
information on whether or not and how
many times a car company has been sued
under the lemon laws I kind of try to
see lemon laws or state laws and I think
the lemon law wasn't you know the the
the format for the lemon law came out of
the Federal Trade Commission and I think
that if anybody would know you know
something like that would be at the
Federal Trade Commission the other thing
now cars like I just bought a car
recently and what amazed me you know
when I Drive about a car in a long time
and when I was like you know most of the
cars I bought was you know I worry about
you how many how good it was for picking
up women or something like that now
though you know family I worry about
different things now and what I did I
took my own advice actually my wife did
when we were going to do this book and
we call up the automobile hotline here
in Washington and they have a hotline
here Department transportation and we
aren't sitting these vamps you know they
either you know Voyager and things like
that I thought that really neat now they
have two kids and my wife has these
visions of taking the softball little
league team around all her life and we
call them up
ask them about safety and they switch to
some research expert and all he does is
crash-test these vans you know in the
sentence the data about how these really
these things really wants to safe you
know and so I really change my mind the
veins but let me give you that 800
number - it's 800 for - for 93 93 that's
800 for 2 for 93 93 the other thing I
would do if you're in a state you said
you're in California called the Attorney
General's office there and asked
committee you must have a lemon law I'm
sure in California and they at least
would know statistics for California
which must do one of the biggest car
buying states in the country and they
would also maybe know if there is a
national clearinghouse okay thank you
very much okay thanks Bill not we're
talking about government information
this hour and and how you can get at our
guest is author Matthew Lesko he's
president of information USA he's been
president since 1983 written for several
magazines and newspapers he was a
regular contributor to National Public
Radio and he's written some other books
in the book called getting yours the
complete guide to government money
another one called the maternity source
book that he wrote with his life that
that he mentioned earlier the computer
data and database source book westco's
new tech source book
he's a former naval officer and has a BS
and an MA in business from Marquette
University and this is the book that
we're referring to this evening it's
information USA the sub headline is the
essential guide for direct access to US
government experts thousands of names
addresses and phone numbers for
information at little or no cost and
further down here it says the Bible of
the information age
lot of this book is related to
information in Washington or I are there
places closer to people's homes where
they can they can go to find out yeah
there's a couple of things once what I'm
getting excited about now is of a state
what's going on a state government you
know with you know the new federalism
and all this thing we hear and and the
so called cutting the budgets which you
know budgets haven't really because we
that's why we have a deficit but they're
what who seems to be picking up the ball
a lot is at the state level you know
it's amazing like if you want to start a
business they have things like at the
state level now call incubator programs
I got into a 61 year old woman
in Minneapolis who always want to start
her own little chocolate factory and she
went to all the banks trying to get
money and they wouldn't help her she got
involved in an incubator program and I
only gave her the money they give her
office space to work out of they give
her free telephone services accounting
services all this stuff you know in
about two years she was doing a quarter
million dollars you know out of a little
chocolate factory that that was from the
state also what I see is a lot of
federal statistical programs you know
are generated from state data which if
you get faster cheaper and whatever from
the state government then you can at the
federal government you know it's just
neat stuff I've been doing like if you
want to know how many restaurants serve
pizza you know in some County you know
you'll have that you know at the state
government you'll get it the federal
government to get is two years later
next calls from Virginia Beach Virginia
we thank you for your patience you're on
the air
yes how are you today good a little bit
information kind of follows up on your
state level thing here in Norfolk at Old
Dominion University library their entire
fourth floor is devoted to government
publication on stacks and stacks and
shelves and shelves and really looking
at it actually a lot of stuff up there
and rarely very many people are in the
fourth floor and they're missing out on
a lot of good stuff up there and for
passed out information about where to
find information that's one good place
to look you bet now actually around the
country they have what call depository
libraries and government depository
libraries and they they're allowed to
have like one free book of everything
the government has but remember what
they're doing is getting only books like
NTIS or or the government printing
office which only is a fraction one-half
of one percent like people say well
let's go what you're talking about is
all that stuff they give out in Pueblo
Colorado no I'm not you know your bank
gives you the runaround you know you're
trying to put a loan together buy a
house you know go to Pueblo Colorado
there's an 800 number if you call the
Federal Deposit Insurance Corporation
now tell your rights and dealing with
the bank you know and if the bank still
gives you the runaround
they'll come out and investigate the
bank for you that's why I want to get
people to use that telephone that's
where you're going to even get better
information generally good Jim another
question Virginia Beach yeah no more
just I really like your book and I'm
going to go pick it up oh thanks it
stuffed on it and thank you very much
appreciate your call next we go it
doesn't kid
the next calls from San Francisco you're
on the air
yes I've got some question for Miss
Wesco I've been working on project right
now trying to identify information about
trade flow between the United States and
the Asian region we've been dealing with
the problem of Commerce Wright has tried
to get information but not with a lot of
luck Oh God I mean what country exactly
you're interested in I'm interested in
all of the countries in Southeast Asia
from Thailand and uncon Singapore
Indonesia there what's interesting a lot
of first of all a CRS Congressional
Research Service just came out with a
nice report on international training
this is a hot item you could just get
inundated with this stuff
the other thing senator Dingell I think
his name is from help me of him I'm
wrong from Michigan he puts out a free
trade newsletter call up his office get
on his mailing list and he does an
analysis of trade every every month let
me give you another thing what I would
do is contact let me give you the number
of the country desk officer what were
some of those countries in Thailand I
mean like Kylie I was doing a study once
I want to know how much polypropylene
resin was imported I mean consumed in
1,500 developed countries and these are
countries where they didn't account
people let alone polypropylene resin I
found there's a world traders a
reference room in the Department of
Commerce that gets the official trade
statistics from every country in the
world before they go to the UN or
anywhere else and there is an original
country of origin but they have people
up there translated like Marlene Ruffin
is the woman who runs this office and
she'll tell you like how many potatoes
are imported into Thailand every year
but here's the Thailand desk officer
Department of Commerce start here is
name is dawn Ryan okay and it's two oh
two three seven seven three eight seven
five two oh two three seven seven three
eight seven five also call her one other
thing I just found on writing up mat
this morning is for like five hundred
dollars the Department of Commerce will
do a market study like you want to know
you you want to sell these cups into
Thailand they'll do a market study for
$500 you know on the potential of
selling these cups in Thailand they'll
give you a listing of about a half a
dozen people who represent you there and
how much and they'll have these
commercial officers run around the
country for you all for 500 bucks you
can't get that anywhere else in the
world for that kind of money San
Francisco let me ask you said you'd run
into some dead ends what what kind of
problems did you have trying to get this
information did they say they didn't
have it well first of all the
information I'm told is extremely old a
number of years and then the every time
we begin to ask some questions that try
to get to some specific information
really what we're told is gee you're
gonna have to come here and go through
the file you don't really have to go
through those file for you do you let me
give you a let's see world trade I could
give you another because that I mean I
do this stuff all the time and I rarely
I mean people think what easy for you
let's go you're on Washington no I'm
lazier than anybody and I never get off
my can to go down and see these people
it's too hard okay here's the a world
import export statistic this is the
place where Marlene rough furnace okay
world trade statistics two oh two three
seven seven four eight five five two oh
two three seven seven four eight five
five and if those things give you a
problem give me a call give you some
more sources okay
Thank You San Francisco our next call
this evening is Chicago
you're on the air thanks for waiting yes
I'd like to ask mr. Lesko where I can
find information on financing a new
small business specifically a dental
practice and general practice okay where
are you Illinois or Storify you're in
Illinois okay my advice nowadays is even
though there's about 50 or 60 programs
in the federal government to finance
businesses whether it's now any kind of
business the best place I think to start
is at the state government because
they're more interested nowadays and an
economic development and they're also
aware of most of the federal programs
problem is the people in the federal
government don't even have Senator Kerry
on Capitol Hill recently did a survey of
all the small business administration
offices about a program they have
to give vietnam-era veterans now you
don't have to be a Vietnam veteran but
just a Vietnam era veterans they give
you like 3% money or something like that
to start a business and only half the
offices knew that there was such a
program so that's that you can't rely on
the people even who are in charge of
giving out the money to know about the
program let me give you a number to
start with
in Springfield okay it's a toll-free
number in Illinois this is the statewide
it's a Business Assistance office in
Illinois it's eight hundred two five two
two nine two three that's 800 two five
two two nine two three that's only going
to work in Illinois okay is that the
information needed Chicago yes what
office is that number four okay that's a
statewide
this is the Business Assistance office
with the small business development
centers these are people in the state
government that helped new businesses
start up with it's any kind of business
is there more additional information in
the book which oh yeah so or actually
just start there because they'll be more
organized on what's available at you
know in the state government they should
be able to give you a listing of the
federal programs also let me give you
the SBA 800 line number now this is for
like second choice okay eight hundred
three six eight five eight five five
eight hundred three six eight five eight
five five they'll tell you about the
major programs that's a problem you know
they'll tell you about four or five
programs when in fact there's about
sixty now all the government money
programs are either in my book or the
book I copied from called the catalog of
federal domestic assistance and that's
available in most public libraries okay
thank you Chicago our next call is
Richland Washington Richland you're on
the air hi mister let's go yes my name
is Paul Brandis liechtenstein I've been
trying to find out about the banking
practice Alexis scientists become a
haven for international banking uh-huh
and yes I most be okay spell it well I'm
one of them I certainly can't what I
would do let me give you the country
desk officer at like you know at the
State Department for Liechtenstein these
people are wonderful they'll tell you I
mean they may not have see any source
that I give you may not have the actual
information but they
we'll tell you who has I mean this is
somebody spending a career studying this
country how big is this country you know
he's going to have to know something
like I had a an uncle who was going to
go to Africa to some country didn't even
know about I'd even know how to spell it
either I called the country desk officer
over there and they told them you know
how safe it was you know to go to this
country they told him who to check into
at the Embassy when he got there if he
was going to go out of the downtown at
night and all this kind of thing they
sent him a free background note on this
country you know that to give them some
data on this country and all this stuff
was for free here's the expert at the
State Department for Liechtenstein you
got a pencil ready ok David Johnson and
it's two oh two six three two two zero
zero five that's two oh two six three
two two zero zero five okay thank you
very much you bet okay thank you
Richland our next call is back to
Illinois Elgin Illinois you're on the
air
yes mr. Roscoe yes yes I think you
grabbed in my Jesus rhetoric you're the
one I know I don't you were at the
beginning the show here I was talking
about the speeding ticket you know and
that's where that came from the last
time I was on Letterman I said you know
you could even find out how to good
information to be the speeding today
right remember that and he asked me do
you know of anybody who dude I said no
well when I got home after that show
some sucker Edmond where were Hazleton
this kid called me up asked me about it
I gave him the address he got it and he
beat a $90 traffic ticket and his mom
called me back a week later
and I thanked me you know is really a
perfect America you are I was just
wondering is there any grants or
government loans on day care centers in
Illinois my wife and I would like to
start one up you know I mean it's going
to vary from state to state now this to
me is a hot item for business like right
here in Fairfax County they have an
office just just at the county level to
help people start daycare centers find
the money get them started and things
like this the national consumer
co-operative bank you know it man they
have an 800 number
they've also financed state care centers
let me give you their 800 number eight
hundred four two four two four eight one
that's 800 four two four two four eight
one but what I would do first of all and
actually when I was up in Boston as a
result of somebody saw me on Letterman
and actually
yeah kitty was 16 at the time and I hope
to get $3,000 from the Department of
Agriculture to start a lawn more service
business and he's now involved in an
entrepreneurs club and I went up there
and talked to somebody talked to their
club and one of them is starting a
daycare center and they're getting help
at the state government you know to
start that Center this is a young woman
you know about 21 years old so let me
give you the state office in Illinois
it's 802 five two two nine two three
that's 802 five two two nine two three
okay thank you very much okay thank you
Alton our next call is from San Diego
you're on the air another sandy getting
information on American journalists and
where does United States news come from
I'd like to know that I believe
Associated Press is run I think it
reaches 1 billion people worldwide if
you could tell me I'm not sure that the
question again what was that quit you
want to know about American journalists
yes I want to get their background Oh
for a specific jobs or more specific yes
but you're no less in general American
journalists run to write for the
newspapers in other words you're looking
for an individual and I'm a little
confused get the background on
journalists for example let's say a
Walter Cronkite you are knows background
okay if any one major what I would do is
go to library and I'll be a who's who
you know that will do that if that if
that doesn't help you what to do there's
another book in the library called gales
and cyclopædia of associations it's GA
le s and cyclopædia of associations
remember for any journalism you know
profession will be an association of
these things you know whether it's
sealed commentators on c-span probably
have you know their own Association I
hear there's about 18 of them or
something like that you know and you
could find there they're identified
these associations and this encyclopedia
and you call up the associations and
that's another place for finding this
people in the government they I can't
think of offhand where they would have
biographies the other thing I would do
is the Library of Congress would help
you okay let me give you their number up
there that and the place to do it is the
national referral center this is an
organization will find you a free expert
on any subject anywhere in the world and
their services are for free however the
budget would just cut ahead so you can
only write to them and you can't phone
them this is the neatest thing in the
government information nobody used it so
they cut it out it was ridiculous okay
it's called the national referral center
they'll still what to do I'll do they'll
run their database and send you out the
printout for free so if you put in
journalism they'll send you like a list
of 20 or 30 organizations around the
country that will give up free
information anything to a journalist
national referral center Library of
Congress Washington DC 205 for oh that's
205 for oh okay okay thank you San Diego
back to the necks of East Coast we go a
family like my mom come on yeah here yes
thank you
I'm calling from Miami before I ask my
question let me express my gratitude to
c-span for changing my entire life in
terms of bringing me information about
the workings of our government and
society I'm a schoolteacher and I do not
hesitate at all to take aspects of
programs into the classroom and to try
to make my students more aware I'm
calling in reference to the sources of
financial aid that you mentioned I am
considering reapplying or re-entering
school to study law and I'm a school
teacher salary you can imagine the
difficulties that I'm having in terms of
thinking about finances right
what advice can you give me in terms of
those sources I know
universities generally give it but I'm I
don't want to rely solely on an
expectation from from any university I
want some other resources okay let me
you have a pencil let me give you the
starting point so in other words in the
government there's about 70 sources of
student financial aid and I know for law
mean most of them are general in nature
some of them are grants some of their
loans from the loan guarantee some of
the specific areas like if you want to
be a nurse or a food scientist you know
you can get like a I want to get a
master's in food science you know the
Department of Agriculture is money for
that you want to get a masters in
mathematic there's a special promo
Department of Energy to help you do that
or a high-technology degree for lawyer
there is I know one identified for
lawyers for minorities there's special
money now that's listed either
again in my book read of the book that
really gives more information because I
what I do is take about a paragraph out
of the book whether the book I copy from
has a whole page on it it's called the
catalog of federal domestic assistance
and if you look under education and the
index there you will see the 60
different programs that's right copy
from the hot the student hot line adds
the Department of Education apart of
education is really giving up more money
than ever before but they it's just not
growing as fast so a lot of people read
the headlines about changing
requirements you know and some family in
south succotash can't get money anymore
so everybody thinks there's no more
money but there is you know here's the
hot land they what they did cut out
there was the 800 number it's now a toll
number it's 301 984 407 Oh 301 984 407
oh there's another thing you should look
at is independent sources not federal
government but also private sources and
there's something called a Foundation
Center up in New York City you know that
really identifies private sources of
money you know whether it's coming from
a company or foundation of some kind
like that and they have an 800 number
that will help you they'll show you
where in your area say where Miami you
could find the reference books to help
you there are 800 numbers eight hundred
four to four nine eight three six eight
hundred four to four nine eight thirty
six okay you know you didn't mention
that there was a program for minorities
yes there was a lot of program for
minorities there's one program I know
III don't I know it's in the catalog of
federal domestic assistance all of my
book and you could identify it there but
I'm sure there's more of the programs by
going through the Foundation Center also
your state government thank you thank
you very you bet but the good work and
God bless you thank you thank you Miami
we talked a lot about information
tonight but there been several questions
about about money and you've looked into
that too what's the scope of the money
that the government has available and
how they have access to well I don't
estimate there's about every year about
five thousand bucks per u.s. adult is
given out you know and has a loan a
grants a direct payment or whatever and
that's only the federal level that
doesn't count for the state level also
what's happening because of the
headlines about budget cuts fewer people
are applying for this stuff you know
when actually they'll have the same
budget as last year but
locations will be down 30% you know
because I'm not people applied you know
like right here in we have a program at
the Department of Housing and Urban
Development called the urban
homesteading act where they give out
houses for a dollar Oh a suburb of
Washington about four or five months ago
they had four of these houses that gave
out they they actually gave them out I
think for $100 their rundown houses so
they're not in real good shape but what
they did everyone who got a house got
$25,000 at 3% interest and fix up the
house you know and only 25 people
applied to these you know to get these
four houses I mean there's an income
level you couldn't make more than
$40,000 a year or whatever but 25 people
applied for four houses where people
lined up in rows says play the state
lottery where you have a one in a
zillion chance that just you know it's
information people don't know about it's
happening our next call back to Boulder
Colorado you're on the air back to
Boulder no first of all I want to know
about your book oh great guys this is my
dad calling me oh that works is that
book lovely or I'll have to write away
no no any bookstore should have it it's
called the information USA without this
little sticker on it and any bookstore
should have it if they done they could
get it a lot easier than going to the
publisher the publisher is penguin and
libraries are stocking it pretty well
too because it was like voted the best
reference book of the year or something
like that so most libraries haven't do
but if people you don't even need the
books if you believe the information is
there you know I mean this will just
maybe enlighten you about the different
kind of things you could get you know I
mean like your kids could get a free
airplane right you're out in Boulder
Colorado you got a lot of air force
bases out there right well you can take
your kids like Cub Scout group or any
kind of get a half a dozen kids together
contact the youth project coordination
officer at your local Air Force Base and
I'll take them on a free airplane ride
now there's a good neat stop you get
free videotapes you get video tapes like
from the National Library of Medicine on
any health problem they had one I saw it
called hemorrhoids management even and
it is just all the latest caused cures
and development in hemorrhoid Joan and
all that is free the best information in
the world
fantastic one more question you
mentioned just a moment ago about the
Vietnam era veteran with the three
right okay let me give you the 800
number 800 s an SBA program 836 eight
five eight five five 836 eight five
eight five five they also have money set
aside for handicapped people to start
businesses these are Direct Loans you
know I talked to a woman right out here
in Columbia Maryland she called me up
she said she heard about me on a radio
show a year or so ago got my book
applied for a direct loan from the Small
Business Administration this is a woman
she was starting an ad agency they
wouldn't give her them money she went
like $25,000 to start a video kind of an
advertising agency and because they said
because she's involved in editorial and
anybody like c-span couldn't get money
from the Small Business Administration
anybody has any editorial content
newspapers things like that they thought
her advertising agency had edit or well
she worked for the congressman and tried
to explain now the SBA that it wasn't
you know she didn't have editorial
content and anything she was doing she
worked with her senators she went to all
the government banging all all the doors
for about six months nothing happened
and you know like about a year ago what
she did she wrote a letter to the
President and said she was this poor
woman you know it was like twenty four
years old
you know hustling trying to start a
business within a week and a half
the SBA called her and said we were
asked to call you and look into this
from the president's office
two weeks later she had $25,000 okay
those are the only place someone is
there any segregated funds for Vietnam
era veterans were disabled well there's
a disabled program and there's a Vietnam
era veterans program so I would play the
plight of both of them that's another
thing you know if you will plot you
there's no rule that you can apply to
fifteen different programs you know some
of them may ask you if you're applying
elsewhere and some of them won't I mean
the worst that could happen is if you
get all the money right and you worry
about that problem you know if it
happens okay so thank you very much you
bet
okay thank you for your call Boulder our
next call is evenings from Massachusetts
is it pronounced wallbang Massachusetts
yes I didn't know nunya
yes hey nice to be with you and I enjoy
listening to mr. Lesko and I think he
serves a a very informative purpose this
call is not totally complimentary
however and I don't mean to be too
critical and I'm not
cuz I'm leaving one bathroom two points
first of all I think he should should
define a little bit more the difference
between information and the difference
between applications and programs for
example I think he helped us all when he
tells us about the various agencies of
the federal government which give
information but also but when he
switches over and talks about programs
you applied for it for money when his
wife is applying to am parks I think he
ought to talk a little bit more like in
a lottery that's very hard to get an
employed program if you don't know
people and to go back in information I
think he should be careful when he talks
about Liechtenstein for example in the
Liechtenstein country officers I think
it's important that he not asked that
person who has an important program and
point in the State Department to be a
travel agent there are a lot of things
that travel agent could tell that the
State Department country officer
shouldn't donate incidentally I think he
will find that that all those country
offices no longer has six three two
numbers in the State Department rewrite
they're all now six four seven numbers I
think he was a little out of date on
that and but I I'm not bothered about
that I think it's information point is
well-taken I'm just a little bit more
about it that he tell people that a lot
of the programs that they applied for
companies apply for a consulting firms
and maybe should talk about that it's a
little bit harder to to get into some of
these programs well I'm telling you but
I do agree that he's serving a good
informational you're right my mom and I
thank you for doing okay yeah I
appreciate that and that's the reality
of it is exactly that you're not gonna
make a phone call and you know in next
Wednesday get a check in the mail for
$50,000 to travel around the world
learning it doesn't happen that way but
what bothers me about it is that the
same people go back and use this every
year you know and when I see a handful
of people using the same thing if you're
like my fortune for fortune 500 clients
use all this stuff you know and
everybody has access to it everyone pays
that most of my clients don't even pay
taxes and use this stuff what bothers me
is that the poor guy down the street
thinks I can't get it well the poor guy
on the street can get it if he plies you
may not get it the first time but you
have to learn the game and if you don't
learn the game
we're going to get anything San Jose
California you're our next call go ahead
whoo yeah San Jose yeah Your Honor here
may have to see I'm from San Jose
California I'm trying to finance a toxic
waste incinerator
and I'm getting the runaround from all
kind of different government offices
government authors is in the state or in
the federal government
San Jose yes you're getting the
runaround from state government offices
or from federal government offices bull
I see the place I would start to give
you one place to start would be at the
state level only because the states are
probably more active in helping small
businesses get started now there's a
number of places in San Diego to start
let me find you a good place look at
there's California innovation of
development loans let me give you some
phone numbers you ready okay office of
business development 906 3 2 2 5 6 6 5 9
1 6 3 2 2 5 6 6 5 okay there's also
small business loan guarantees okay
that's from the same office so that
looks like the main offices start with
or there's an office of small business
in Sacramento at a nine hundred six four
four five six five four five that's 900
six four four five six five four five
the problem is that the toxic waste
incinerator cost around ten million
dollar to to build and when you're
talking about 10 million dollars nobody
you really want to talk to you all right
is it going supplying a lot of jobs or
not or sure well it's going to clean a
lot of fit dump site this valiant mobile
incinerator I mean to me 10 million
dollars that you know for financing the
state programs is really not you know in
heard of I mean I've run into cases I
mean somebody got a 10 million dollars
the state of Connecticut for a leveraged
buyout you know of an existing
organization the other thing I mean the
state governments will also help you
find private
sources of financing not only the
federal government but help you find you
know you know investors or institutional
investors venture capital help you put
together you know packages and help you
start shopping another thing you may
want to do is look for a what they call
a venture capital clubs that are around
the country now you said you were in
California forget we're in San Diego San
Jose San Jose see if there's a local
venture capital club or this is a club
where you you present your package to
people looking for investments you know
and they're not you know people looking
to best $5,000 you know it substantial
sums of money usually so that's another
source of relax okay thank you for your
call to San Jose our last call last call
tonight is a Haven Connecticut bow go
ahead hello New Haven New Haven you
still with us
Haven we must have lots of the Train
okay one of the things that I found and
we can start to wrap this stuff one of
the things I found in your book that you
mentioned several times is about because
some of the unsung heroes of all of this
are bureaucrats in fact if you dedicate
you say at all the federal bureaucrat I
you before I came to Washington I
thought anybody who got anything out of
Washington had to be real real poor or
real real rich or something like that
and take a congressman to Center to
lunch and but it's not it's these
bureaucrats them that are here they die
in to help you you know just that nobody
uses them and that's the wastefulness I
see in the government that nobody uses
the government because people in the
government don't even use it you know so
if taxpayers start using this
particularly in an Information Age you
know we could be a world leader again if
we learn to harness this information
when you go to the bureaucrats and ask
for this information there's a reception
to get well it depends on how you act
towards them see what happens I think
the typical person out there the
taxpayer makes one or two phone calls
gets the bureaucratic runaround and
finally gets this expert who could help
them you know get money to build a
catfish farm or whatever and they start
yelling and screaming to this third
bureaucrat because they made four or
five phone calls you know nobody's
helped them so you have to remember
these folks are just like your neighbor
you know they're not sitting there lazy
all day they want to help you but you
have to give him a chance and most of us
don't our topic for the past hours then
government information and how to get it
it's obvious we could go on for several
more hours about this we'd like to thank
all of our viewers for their questions
and comments and our guests our guest
Matthew Lesko he's compiled information
USA about government information have a
good evening